there is no corner of this world you
have not explored no geography of the
soul which you can't look now the
mr. Shakespeare I don't want to pester
you good excellent news cheerio
I just wanted to ask you the best way to
get started as a writer is to start
writing no really good I just I don't
have a favorite play I admire all my
fellow dramatist equally and yes I do
think women should be allowed to perform
the female roles as bees the practice on
the continent now please if you'll
excuse me are you coming no more stories
left to right I've lived so long in
imaginary worlds I think I've lost sight
of what is real well your Miss Church
here don't find you your telling has a
greater scope than all the other birds
and if you lived the smallest life
family is everything it's love not
ambition that will blossom in this
garden well something has to I'm not a
good gardener it's true my husband
thinks you've come for him to die
I've just caught a pension I can't die
for at least 10 years where I'll be
ruined you went to London and became
this great writer with a wife at home
you were hardly here it worse you're a
guest
good night husband
retirement hasn't exactly brought the
peace we might have hoped for and he was
right about people why are you stop
writing I've never let the truth get in
the way of a good story
[Music]
Weezer's worried about your reputation
have you even once considered minor true
light she is approps a man fortune to
this house head of this family
[Music]
if you're honest with yourself and
whatever you write all is true
[Music]
you